[Musique]
bonsoir avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous sur rc france alors de quoi
sont accusées ces hackers russes par les
états unis
alors ces six ressortissants russes qui
appartiendrait aux généreux services de
renseignement sont accusés d' opération
de piratage massives au niveau
international les jo de séoul mais aussi
un rang de somewhere notre petya qui
avait eu lieu entre 2015 et 2019
l'attak aussi en grande bretagne des
personnes qui travaillaient sur la
sphère three palais et d'autres comme ça
et en france cette affaire des macros
l'x les six hackers russes sont accusées
d'avoir espionné et recueillie le
courrier de plus de 100 membres du staff
des manades macron en mai et avril 2010
est pendant la campagne présidentielle
alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans ses
fameux macronix alors danser macronix il
y a à la fois du vrai et du faux c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu plusieurs adresses mail
qui ont été récupérés et ses mails sont
sortis à la fois mail personnel mes
mails de campagne vous avez deux dans
des factures tout simplement des
échanges personnels des commandes de
taxi des notes des notes d'intention sur
les thèmes de campagne et tout ça était
rassemblée de manière assez sommaire
c'est à dire que la technologie qui a
permis de récupérer ses mails n'est pas
à la hauteur d'un service secret
internationale qui aurait fait ça avec
des technologies qui finalement son
talent
à la portée du premier hacker venu
dirons nous et donc lorsque ccc macronix
sont sortis le timing était aussi assez
étrange puisque le hacking s'était fait
autour du 24 avril et c'est quinze jours
plus tard la veille du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle que sorte
celle x ses mails alors même que les
candidats sont tenus de devoir de
réserve ne plus commenter l'actualité
que parce que c'est un week end
électoral
donc on peut on peut se poser la
question du timing et de la façon dont
ces informations ont été recueillies
parmi les faux il y avait notamment des
députés qui se sont retrouvés accusé de
commandes et de la drogue de synthèse
depuis leurs emails de l'assemblée
nationale qui ont porté plainte
d'ailleurs et d'autres affaires qui sont
sortis lors lors de lors de celle x
l'équipe de campagne avait parlé de
désinformation et avait montré du doigt
immédiatement la russie sans preuve
ce qui a permis l'ouverture d'une
enquête après l'élection de pas par la
dgs i et puis le lait la façon dont
emmanuel macron avait traité rt france
dès qu'il avait reçu vladimir poutine à
versailles en accusant la chaîne d'être
un organe de propagande donc voilà un
peu les maquereaux l'x mais finalement
peu de choses dedans qui ont été
exploitées à date on n'apprend rien donc
et la commission des comptes de campagne
n'a pas jugé opportun d'enquêté non la
commission des comptes de campagne mais
encore une fois nous nous sommes en
france n'a pas elle été chercher plus
loin alors qu'il y avait eu d'autres
informations en dehors de ces macronix
sur la campagne des malaises macro
notamment de prêts de salles de dons
extrêmement généreux qu'il avait pu
avoir par le réseau de gérard collomb à
l'époque tout ça n'a pas été
épluchez par la commission des comptes
de campagne qui est sous staff et comme
beaucoup de commissions en france et
dont d'ailleurs le responsable a été
augmenté immédiatement après l'élection
par emmanuel macron et en france on a
quand même il faut dire une drôle
d'habitude avec le financement des
partis politiques qui reste extrêmement
opaque et notamment des campagnes
politiques pour bien revenir sur les
histoires les affaires passées il veut
la faire urbain dans les années 80 pour
le parti socialiste
plus proche de nous la faire du
financement libyen de la campagne de
2007 de nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy
vient d'être mis en examen pour
association de malfaiteurs il était déjà
mis en examen pour détournement d'argent
libyen
là encore la justice devra faire son
travail et puis on apprend que le
conseil constitutionnel lui qui avait
validé les comptes de campagne de 1995
de jacques chirac edouard balladur avait
agi contre le droit puisque à l'époque
que ce soit jacques chirac le douar
balladur les deux avaient reçu de
l'argent liquide sans que la provenance
et pu être attestée
c'était 10 millions de francs pour
edouard balladur qui avait été remis
dans des sacs en toile et 3 millions de
francs qui avait été remis à la campagne
de jacques chirac qui n'était pas
justifiée dans les comptes de campagne
et on a appris récemment que le conseil
constitutionnel est bien a décidé de
valider ses comptes malgré les
irrégularités
pourtant avérée donc on peut vraiment se
poser la question en france du
financement de la politique et la façon
dont les partis se financent par les
dons à la fois et par des réseaux
occultes
l' affaire karachi qui va être jugé bien
sûr pour la campagne d'edouard balladur
en janvier 2021
mais voyez le temps que ça prend plus
d'une vingtaine d'années pour que la
justice s'intéresse à ses comptes de
campagne pour que l'on cherche enfin à
savoir non pas qu'elle a été l'un
gérance d'un état extérieur à la france
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec les
réseaux français des candidats
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes